qué podemos esperar del de venir de este
conflicto en las próximas horas
Buenos días a ver hay varios y está
escuchando como varias aspectos y lo
primero es que yo quería o sea lo
primero que no tiene que pensar es que
Vladimir lanzó un ataque y no es que ser
eso demoledor porque realmente las
imágenes aún son confusas pero no es un
ataque de moledor pero sí lanzó Ya dijo
claramente
que el ataque que sí tenía todas las
posibilidad porque occidente y yo creo
que eran yo creo que manden 90 95% los
analistas básicamente decían que esto
era un farol que esto que estaba en un
juego de poker y que me iba a hacer nada
aquí está claro dice ya está aprobado el
terreno acaba de lanzarlo accidente
claramente la señal de qué sí iba a
lanzar el ataque es claro eso Y creo que
esto es una guerra que se va a convertir
en una guerra local
que Ucrania jamás entra la otan que sea
un estado satélite de Rusia
partir el mapa de Ucrania prácticamente
yo creo que ya ese objetivo
prácticamente yo lo tiene ya cumplido y
dejarle ir a verle puesto el
revolverse al a Moscú Vladimir Putin con
una victoria en la mano y no hay uno
después de haber movilizado de 150,000 a
200,000 hombres era muy difícil que esto
no se fuera a dar y además los plazos
estamos en el en la finalización del
invierno en Rusia después de que viales
el invierno empieza el barro y empieza a
ser complicado movilizar la logística y
yo también he escuchado varias cosas que
esto
esta movilización empezó hace un año en
el mes de abril lleva movilizando tropa
y no se hizo mayor cosa Y esto escaló y
escaló esto nivel también está
escuchando la anterior analista hablando
de China y sí diplomáticamente puede ser
que sea su comportamiento pero en este
momento el primer socio comercial de
Rusia se llama china
sobrevalorado las sanciones económicas
las sanciones económicas por definición
nunca han tumbado regímenes Y no van
parado conflictos Rusia desde 2014
preparó el plan fortaleza económico Qué
es eso
elevo las reservas internacionales a
600.000 millones de dólares hoy
empezó a hacer a negociar más con yenes
con Johannes y con euros y avión nuevos
socios comerciales como es china el
intercambio con chiroides es de 150.000
millones de dólares y se espera que
llega a los 200,000 millones de dólares
y si viene diplomáticamente no va china
a decir mayor cosa Al respecto porque
ese ese como lo decía anteriormente el
anterior
creo que va a aprovechar la situación
para darle la mano económicamente si va
a estar ahí y China Más allá de de lo
digamos de los simbólicos no apoyaré
estados autonómicos y por el tema de
Taiwán China si requiere que Estados
Unidos esté fuera del Asia y en este
momento Estados Unidos
en Estados Unidos de allí del del teatro
del Asia para mandarle a Europa porque
es que el conflicto futuro y yo se lo lo
advirtiendo es con China y eso va a
hacer una habitación delicada y China
tomaba atenta nota de las debilidades de
occidente tanto de la Unión Europea de
la falta de unidad que encabezó a
Alemania porque Alemania
y los errores que ha cometido
estratégicamente la administración
demócrata en este te